en vieillissant je retrouve mes origines
j'aime les paysages du nord je me suis
très sensible aux paysages du nord
j'aime la ville de lille surtout depuis
qu'on a fait c'est admirable travaux de
restauration qui ont permis de retrouver
ses façades merveilleuse du passé qui
était quand j'étais petit enfoui sous la
crasse on ne soupçonnait pas qu'ils
avaient cessé de si belles maisons à
lille
j'aime la ville de hull j'aime les gens
du nord parce qu'ils sont chaleureux
c'est ce que les gens de du sud même à
paris ne soupçonne pas on croit que les
gens du nord sont des gens froid parce
qu'on la froide ans lorsque pas parti
avant plus fort qu'à yeux et vous
souvenez quand même de sévigné appelé
colbert le nord bon tout ça ça s'éteint
c'est un contexte ben c'est pas vrai les
gens du nord sont très chaleureux et
j'aime la manière dont ils vivent
il y à une sorte de liesse je trouve
dans lors qu il faut il faut il faut
qu'on ne peut pas l'avoir du premier
coup mais on l'a ressemblent quand on se
donne la peine de regarder et je ressens
tout ça maintenant et je me sens bien le
13 mars 1980 alain decaux été reçu à
l'académie française
c'est le premier lillois à qui échoit
cet honneur
qui ne connaît alain decaux auteur de
nombreux ouvrages historiques
homme de théâtre de radio avec la
tribune de l'histoire de télévision avec
la caméra explore le temps et alain
decaux raconte
et vous
mais l'homme l'homme du nord et peut
être moins connus laissons guy la parole
je suis né à lille le 23 juillet 1925 au
numéro 2 de la rue dagerman c'est-à-dire
à l'angle de la place de la république
parce que à cette époque là je le dis
pour les plus jeunes de ceux qui
m'écoutent les les mères de famille à
coucher chez elle c'était la règle
c'était nécessaire et ça n'était
peut-être pas si mal et la première
image que j'ai de moi est une
photographie qui était presque quelques
jours plus tard sur le balcon justement
de l'immeuble de la rue d'inkerman où ma
mère me tient dans ses bras et je
m'aperçois sur cette photographie que ma
mère est d'ailleurs une fort jolie femme
et ma mère était né à lille
mon père était né à lille donc je suis
lillois fils de lillois mais ces lillois
du côté de ma mère oui on est lillois
depuis très longtemps mais mon père
était le premier de co et qui était né à
lille il était fils d'un instituteur mon
grand père henri decaux et d'une
institutrice angèle jeunes qui elle est
et ardennaises mais mon grand père était
n'était pas les lois mais était du
département du nord et il y a quelques
années un généalogiste qui s'appelle
monsieur gilles henry m'a fait la
surprise je ne lui avais rien demandé de
m'envoyer ma généalogie il avait fait
des recherches dans les archives et
c'est ainsi que je sais que la famille
decaux est originaire de cette région du
département du nord depuis 16 150
avançait 150 on trouve rien peut-être
trouvera-t-on à jour mais pour le moment
c'est bouché alors d'où sont ils les
deux co et bien d'un petit village qui
s'appelle escarment et qui dans le sud
du département du nord et depuis 750 les
deux co sont tantôt escarmain tantôt
dans un village qui est tout à côté
vraiment payer les à pied et qui
s'appelle solesmes alors solesmes
escarmain carmin solesmes et qu'est ce
qu'ils font et bien d'après les actes
ils sont paysans bien sûr et puis au 19e
siècle on trouve des vanille il y a dans
la dans une rivière qui traverse
escarmain et sa de loisier alors par
exemple mon arrière-grand-père qui
s'appelait françois françois decaux
était vanier sur certains acquis les
vanniers d'autres manneliers manolios et
son vous savez ces grands paniers plat
alors ça faisait probablement mieux à la
mairie de m manaud liés une coquetterie
du secrétaires des mairies et c'était
des gens très simples bien sûr vous
savez un vannier ça n'a jamais un homme
riche mais il ya toujours eu et c'est ce
qui me plaît surtout dans au 19e siècle
une volonté de deux parents de que leur
enfant est plus loin que et le vannier
françois decaux a voulu que son fils
henri aille plus loin et il en a fait un
instituteur
c'est important les instituteurs surtout
sous la troisième république toujours
aujourd'hui à l'instituteur est toujours
un homme considérable parce que c'est
l'homme qui forme les enfants mais sous
la troisième république
socialement sociologiquement
l'instituteur joue un rôle très
important et très curieux l'instituteur
pour des quantités de famille va être
l'intercesseur entre le prolétariat et
la bourgeoisie
il est il est au milieu il sort du
prolétariat est très souvent ses filles
ces enfants vont eux accéder à la
bourgeoisie on pourrait citer des
centaines d'exemples et donc là henri
decoux va devenir instituteur et après
avoir été instituteur dans des villages
et bien il sera nommé à lille et il
passera de très nombreuses années à
lille ma grand-mère qui l'a rencontré
également qui est institutrice trt est
institutrice dans une autre école mon
grand-père est instituteur à l'école
rollin et c'est d'ailleurs là le corps
l'un que je suivrai une année moi aussi
mon père a fait toutes ses études
primaires à l'école relate l'école
rollin jouent un certain rôle dans notre
vie à mon père et à moi et ma grand mère
elle était institutrice à sophie germain
est là aussi voyez vous on en revient à
cette évolution dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
l'instituteur lui veut que son fils
aille plus loin donc mon père francis
francis de co va faire des études de
droit deviendra docteur en droit et sera
voc sera avocat au barreau de lille et
il se rabat a nié je crois en 1938 et il
ya encore quelques amis de mon père que
je vois quand j'y retourne de vivre très
vieux amis maintenant bien sûr qu'ils
viennent me parler de lui qui viennent
me parler de ma mère je vois que font
les très vieux messieurs quand je fais
des conférences à lille qui mènera à la
belle madame decaux et ça me fait
plaisir bien sûr et quand je rentre je
le dis à ma mère je pense que ça lui
fait plaisir aussi
ans
alors oui bien sûr j'ai fait mes études
d'abord non pas tout de suite à rôle
parce que j'ai passé quelques années
avec mes frères il se trouve que j'ai
deux frères bernard à ebay nous avons
passé quelques années chez ma grand mère
dans les environs de lille à wattignies
templemars pour le bonheur parce qu'on
voulait que mon dieu ne nous est pas
nourrissions dans la campagne wattignies
templemars ne plus tellement la campagne
l'onu mais yahia à cette époque là
c'était encore la pleine campagne nous
avons nous avions après devant la maison
de ma grand-mère où il y avait en
général ça nous amusait beaucoup
et derrière il y avait des champs à
perte de vue on vieillit la moisson à
l'été c'était passionnant parce qu'il y
avait la locomobile à vapeur c'était
extraordinaire de vivre à la campagne
alors oui nous avons vécu à wattignies
templemars et 7 à wattignies templemars
qu à wattignies plus précisément que
j'ai été à l'école pour la première fois
dans la petite école communale qui est
dans le directeur était monsieur rico il
y avait une classe intermédiaire tenus
par madame rico et la petite classe par
monsieur del place je me souviens très
bien
on vient de m'écrire d'ailleurs et j'en
suis attristé précédé le place est
décédé j'ai gardé un très bon souvenir
de mes seidel place est d'ailleurs aussi
le mal à me rico alors oui l'école de
wattignies ensuite l'école rollin et le
lycée faidherbe à lille où j'ai étudié
depuis la 6ème jusqu'à la quatrième
à
mo
les vacances nous allions sur une plage
belge comme beaucoup de gens de l'île
parce que bondues plages belges c'est
tout près c'est 60 km et en même temps
c'est une sorte de dépaysement les
aimions bien les parages belle nous
allions nous dans une petite poche est
maintenant tout à fait fondu avec
laurette mais où il y avait guère que
quelques maisons quand j'étais tout
petit qui s'appelle saint-idesbald et
nous avons loué d'année en année au
moins une dizaine de villes là d'un dans
saint-idesbald et puis d'ailleurs nous
allions sur les plages belges eux
souvent le dimanche nous nous en tation
dans la voiture c'était le temps des
grandes voitures s'étaient pas les
petites voitures le on l'avait laissé de
grandes voitures et on se mettait un
nombre fou de famille là dedans il y
avait je suis ahuri quand je pense à
toutes les personnes de la famille qui
rentrait dans la voiture de mon père
mais naturellement mon père et ma mère
il y avait ma grand mère il y avait mon
oncle et parrain qui est mort par la
suite en allemagne dans un camp de
déportation
il y avait ma tante donc ça faisait
beaucoup beaucoup de gens mes deux
frères et moi vous imaginez tout ça dans
la même voiture moi j'étais toujours
assis à l'avant sur les genoux de mon
parent et mes deux petits frères étaient
assis sur des petits tabourets au fond
de la voiture tout le monde s'entasse et
là dedans et nous arrivions le dimanche
dans les dunes qui s'étendent tout le
monde les déploie le belge alors on
cherchait un endroit abrité dans ces
dunes abrité du vent parce que beaucoup
de vent surtout l'hiver parce qu'on est
allé aussi l'hiver et le mas grand-mère
en général avait fait un lapin froid
avec dans un saladier une salade de
pommes de terre et c'était de cdd de
merveilleux souvenirs cessé dimanche à
la mer
et puis ça a été la guerre 1939 et j'ai
toujours pensé que les guerres change la
vie des familles c'est certainement
valable à travers l'histoire pour les
milliers de familles des millions
peut-être de famille mon père avait le
souvenir de l'occupation mon père de
14-18 mon père l'ait fait la guerre ma
mère avait subi cette occupation qui a
été terrible terrible avait été la fin
c'était infernal mon grand-père avait
été déporté du travail parce qu'il y
avait aussi les déportés du travail en
14-18 et mon père qui était pessimiste
qui avait fait la guerre qui était
encore mobilisé en 39 qui détale est un
majeur que capitaine de réserve s'était
dit ça va pas se passait bien il
n'imaginait pas comment ça se serait
passé mille îles à penser qu'il y aurait
de nouveau une occupation du nord il a
voulu nous l'épargner
et c'est pour ça que nous sommes partie
des 39 des 70 39
mon père lui mobilisé ma mère mes deux
frères et moi en bretagne chez des
cousins
mais ce fut la débâcle
mon père démobilisés rentrée à lille non
c'était la zone interdite ont
déconseillé à monter en dix romans
attendez attendez attendez bah oui mais
il fallait vivre
alors paris re commencer une carrière
d'avocat paris a 50 ans non et c'est
alors que mon père a sollicité une
nomination à une charge d'administrateur
judiciaire il a été évidemment de
l'éclatante référence il a été nommé
tout de suite et il a fini sa vie comme
administrateur judiciaire pour tribunal
civil de paris et c'est ainsi que je
suis devenu parisien
c'est ainsi que j'ai pu faire cette
carrière parce que entre nous aurais-je
pu faire cette carrière ailleurs
peut-être pas c'est triste parce que moi
je ne suis pas pour la centralisation
mais c'est ainsi quand j'ai pris ce goût
de l'histoire la volonté d'écrire le
désir absolu des cris et quand j'ai
voulu en faire un métier en vivre et
bien oui il fallait que ce soit paris
j'ai trouvé un éditeur pour mon premier
livre faire de la radio donc à paris
faire de la télévision donc à paris donc
c'est un peu la guerre finalement qui a
fait de moi ce que je suis alors mon
métier mon métier vous le savez est axé
sur l'histoire il se déroule sur trois
plans le
vivre la radio la télévision il me donne
des joies immenses depuis le premier
jour j'ai su que ce métier me donnerai
toutes ces joies et ce qui me fait
plaisir ce qui est pour moi une autre
loi c'est que j'exerce ce métier depuis
plus de trente ans et que je ne suis pas
blasé que les joies de la curiosité et
que j'avais à 20 ans je les ai toujours
eu
quand j'aborde un nouveau sujet bien je
suis toujours aussi passionné alors je
n'ai qu'un désir à formuler c'est comme
disait madame l'éthicien pourvu que ça
dure mais je crois que ça du roi